meg made her first public appearance in
14 months looking flawless at the
Schiaparelli show the 53 year old smooth
complexion and bright eyes processed
some to speculate she has had some work
done was described as the perky girl
next door of make his face criticism in
the past for allegedly altering her
looks at the Georges Chakra show she
wore a lace bare shoulder beaded number
by chakra himself Julia having a fan
moment with Isabella Rossellini one of
the first celebrity faces off the
cosmetics giant they joined fellow
Lancome ambassadors Penelope Cruz Lupita
Nyong'o and Kate Winslet for the beauty
brands 80th birthday bash last night and
nothing is getting between Kendall
Jenner and her well you know today I
felt super good and super sexy and my
Calvin Klein underwear kendall is one of
four models bearing almost all in the
original sexy fall campaign and we have
your first look at the new ad first
thing that I wore was really beautiful
was like a lace bra kind of see-through
but her all-time favorite Calvin
campaign most iconic Calvin Klein
underwear campaign would definitely be
Kate Moss and Mark Wahlberg it's my
favorite model things working out quite
well for Kendall in fact he is up for a
choice model at Teen Choice Awards
airing next month on Fox